Vũ Hắc Keez, sớt hiện thêm một cóp nhìn mới từ phía Trung Quốc.
Cộthè, kìa hội công nghiệp dấy Trung Quốc đã lên tiếng nhận định rằng
cần làm gió thêm một số thông tin trước khi có thể đưa ra phết lận quý cùng về vụ việc.
Theo phía hệ hệ hội, tính đến thời điểm diện tại, sương pháp kìm nghiệp được áp dụ vẫn chưa được cộng bố đề đủ.
Bình cạnh đó, quy chính lấy mẫu, cách thức bảo quan cũng như điều kiện sự dụ của các mẫu được mang đi kiểm tra
cũng chưa được thông tin mình bạn.
Một điểm đáng lưu tâm khác là việc phát hiện phó mà mai trong cơ thể chẻ, rồi cho rằng
quyền nhân bắt buồn từ tả giới vẫn cần thêm giữ điều để đối chíu hát quan.
Theo hệ hội, cần xem sét kỷ lưỡi, liệu các bé có đang chíu anh hưởng từ những buồn tiếp xúc
tìm ở nào trong cuộc sống hàng ngày không?
Đông thời, hệ hội cũng cho biết, các nhận hàng liên quan đã chủ động vời sản phẩm đến các phòng
vĩ nghiệp đã chính nhận CMI để tiến hành kìm nghiệp và đang tiếp tục bộ sung thêm giữ điều.
Đến thời điểm hiện tại, vụ việc vẫn đang được các bê liên quan tiếp tục làm gió.
Ví thế, bà mẹ nên giữ bình tính và tiếp tục theo dõi thêm các thùng viên chính thức trong thời gian tới để có cái nhìn toàn dịch phát quan nhất về sự việc nhà.